first the terror watchlist we heard
about that right now border agents say
they stopped a member of the deadly
ms-13 gang
from sneaking into the u.s but what
about the criminals who are
able to get through the ones that are
good at being
deceitful our next guest knows all about
it his older brother rocky was shot and
killed by a criminal an illegal alien at
the time
that was back in december of 2018 after
being arrested and released
under california's sanctuary policy jody
joins us
uh joins us right now jody we're seeing
these numbers the staggering numbers of
people coming through the border that we
catch
what about the ones we don't before we
get that story in your perception tell
us what happened to your brother
uh good morning thank you for having me
first of all um he
was murdered in 2018 by a illegal
criminal alien that was arrested
two days prior and because of the
sanctuary city laws
he was released and shot murdered by
this criminal so he was uh this guy's
name is gustavo garcia
he was arrested on a drug charge held in
a jail for about 10 hours
then he was responsible for several
shootings two other murders carjackings
multiple high-speed chases
so this guy's a true menace uh he's hell
on earth
and he's still here and your brother
isn't
when you hear about an arrest of two two
yemeni terrorists
and then you hear about an ms-13 arrest
what are you thinking
along with the 19 000 unaccompanied
minors who are just streaming
into our country we absolutely have a
crisis
all you hear is law enforcement agencies
screaming for help
and there's there's nothing being done
um
we have a saying in law enforcement if
it walks like a duck
talks like a duck it's not a cow it's a
duck so don't sit there and tell me that
there's not a crisis down at the border
because there is all you have to do is
listen and see
to know that it's a crisis we had more
illegal immigrants
across our southern border last month
than ever before in history
think about that in history right and
truly it's truly amazing what's going on
down there and of course
the way it goes and you would know this
better than i is that you send the
families who are no threat
you send the kids who are no threat the
border agents go there
and then in comes ms-13 or the drug
traffickers
with the fentanyl that are poisoning the
country they think well i'm not in a
border city it doesn't involve me but
that's just not the case
you're right it isn't the case uh just
think of how many that's getting across
and it's coming into our communities
it's really destroying our communities
we have here in california sb 54
it really drove a wedge between law
enforcement local law enforcement and
immigration
it just stopped them from communicating
with each other now we have proposed
bills here in california
there's an ab-937 if you strip that bill
away
really what it does is it just makes it
impossible against the law actually
to deport or remove any felon uh illegal
immigrant that commits a felony
you just can't deport them it's insanity
what's going on here
but the hhs secretary was once a deputy
hhs secretary
he knows how this works he knows the
need for ice
yet when it comes to sanctuary cities
what has ice been told to do
stand down or get out right that's
absolutely right uh
their hands are tied uh you could just
look at the pictures what's going down
down down
in the border it's it's just like that
in our communities
these felons are committing crimes these
illegal immigrants are committing crimes
felons felonies
uh getting caught with pounds of
methamphetamines
weapons on them firearms nothing's
happening to them
i mean they're doing literally hours in
jail and getting released
you know ab54 the sanctuary city laws
immigration has to have
a federal warrant to to have these local
law enforcement agencies hold them
and it's impossible to to do that and
they just don't seem to care
uh they don't seem to care uh that's
that's
sad look i'm not a politician i'm not a
governor i'm not a senator i'm not a
congressman
i'm i'm just i'm a citizen i'm an
american citizen
and what's going on right now is they're
protecting the
criminals illegal alien criminals and
when you start doing that when you're
protecting them
you stop protecting our our community
you stop protecting our our american
citizens
uh jodie jones this isn't red or red or
blue this is right and wrong
and what's happening now is flat out
wrong and that's what you're pointing
out
uh in memory of your brother you're
doing that that's why you scrambled to
get up this morning uh rocky who was
killed two years ago
if i could say one last thing please i
heard president biden yesterday say
that it's his job to protect the
american people well i want to say to
president biden please protect american
people
secure our southern borders do it now do
it soon
because it's getting worse by the minute
by the hour by the day yep and we can't
even get the vice president president to
show up
thanks so much appreciate it absolutely
thank you